Reid is with us in Alabama I read
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how you feeling today better than I
deserve sir how can I help so I am 23
and my wife and I have about a hundred
and forty thousand and student loans
together and we are paying it off as
furnaces and possibly can but I think
that some of our interest rates are kind
of high we have some variable interest
rates as well as fixed and I'm curious
at what point do you think we should
consolidate like how bad is too bad of
interest rates well if you can save
money on the interest on a student loan
and you can go from variable rate to
fixed rate and you can go from a higher
fixed rate to a lower fixed rate then
that's when consolidation is in order
now the question is you've got to go
through the hassle of fooling with all
of this how much is it actually going to
save you in real dollars when you do
that and for how many years how long are
you going to be in debt what's the total
of your student loan debt it's a hundred
and forty thousand okay and what's your
household income take home or salary
salaries what I don't know what mean
what's your gross income for the year
for the whole household bonus is
everything
probably just a hundred or one just got
a job recently so probably about a
hundred so in the coming 12 months you
guys are like a hundred thousand bucks
yeah and then out of that obvious
understand understand okay so what in
the world who got who got the expensive
degree we both did
we weren't smart with our money and we
didn't we didn't hear about you until
after we well I guess right before we
got married
right after we graduated so we've just
been trying to be gizelle intense and
make up for our stupidity gotcha okay so
what are your degrees in I'm a
mechanical engineer and she's a
Elementary teacher okay so you just
overpaid for the degrees oh yeah okay
pretty much okay all right so we got
$140,000 to clean up making a hundred
and so I mean I just do big numbers
around here so if you did fifty a year
for three years you'd be debt-free
during that during that three years and
that's that's beans and rice rice and
beans and you're not having any life and
you're probably hoping to see some
increases during that time to actually
make that work so you have a three year
journey at least maybe a little bit more
now if you save one percent on 140,000
bucks you say fourteen hundred dollars a
year if you did that for three years of
course you wouldn't have that much out
for three years because you're reducing
it every year but we're talking about a
$5,000 savings through that period of
time so $5,000 does not solve your
hundred and forty thousand not a problem
but if you send me five thousand dollars
I'll take it yeah so it isn't it isn't
the answer to the issue the answer the
issue of beans and rice rice and beans
but it'd be nice to not give them an
extra five thousand dollars during this
three years that you're doing this and
that's if you saved only one percent
during that time I don't know what
you'll save you can only find that out
once you find out what the rate is
they're offering you on the
consolidation compare that to your
existing rates and certainly compare it
to your adjustables you want to get rid
of those things for sure because that
represents increased risk